you remember about 20 years ago or so
when baby Jessica fell down the well and
they look they they found a guy who was
born without shoulder blades and lowered
him down the little narrow thing and it
was like wow that guy was waiting by the
phone for that for so long and it
finally came banshee was the man without
shoulder blade he doesn't really have a
lot of use he makes sound but when we
were coming up with when we were
designing the third act and it was like
okay Sebastian Shaw the cool groovy dude
in his cool groovy submarine they can't
find him he's down there somewhere how
they gonna find him wait we've got a guy
who makes sound drop him into the ocean
and he's a sonar buoy that's all active
sonar is as bright intense sound that
you bounce back bats do it dolphins do
it that's he may not do much but he does
what you know like Wolverine but you
know actually what he does is very nice
in this case so he's not like Wolverine
right he does it very well we went
through so many mutants and so there
there were so many different there's so
many different alternate universe
versions of this with if any any variety
of mutants but ban she was in a lot of
different versions and he you know he
was doing things at one point we had
Banshee and we had Banshee and dazzler
and you know because dazzler can turn
sound and delight an earlier writer and
we took the idea from the earlier writer
had Banshee make intense sound and then
she turned it into a laser that was
really that was really cool but but yeah
we had you know all of the sudden in the
third act this guy who you know he was
kind of the Ringo of the he was kind of
the Ringo of the of the x-men finally
had his moment yeah this guy he's got
him it sound pulses he can find where
the submarine is perfect there are
actual human beings a few human beings
that have that seemed to have limited
sonar capabilities people who are born
blind and things like that actually can
find people by
location yeah and that kind of stuff
really it's really quite interesting
when you put that kind of stuff in
because you you go yeah you know that
that makes sense that's a great use for
it yeah in the world of this story
telling you know the the the idea behind
the x-men that that these mutants are to
humans is we are to Neanderthals but
they do all kinds of things that you
know what are the laws of physics behind
what they can all do I don't know that's
the that is the hand wave but within
that you try and find realistic and
interesting things for them to do